Raymond Cruz made an indelible
impression on television viewers with
his instantly unforgettable performance
as bad guy Tuco Salamanca on Breaking
Bad the character proved so popular they
brought him back for the prequel
spin-off better call Saul so it's a bit
surprising that Cruz hasn't gotten more
recognition until now that is
here's a look at the untold truth about
the guy who played Tuco on Breaking Bad
gang hit
maybe the eeriest thing about Cruz's
performance on Breaking Bad is how fully
and comfortably he seems to inhabit
Tuco's world of drug running and gang
banging but there's a good reason for
that
Cruz himself grew up surrounded by
hardcore gang activity on the
hardscrabble streets of East LA how bad
was it he told The Daily Beast that when
he was just 12 he witnessed a
cold-blooded homicide I saw someone get
shot in front of me at point-blank range
the brains came out the back of his head
yikes by the book as a kid Cruz escaped
the world of street gangs both literally
and metaphorically through his love of
literature retreating into books he read
and reread classic novels and that
passion eventually led him to acting
thanks in part to an assist from Gregory
Peck Cruz told smashing interviews I was
fascinated by the translation of the
written word to performance I read
Harper Lee's To Kill a Mockingbird and
it was one of my favorite books then
when I saw the movie I was over the moon
about it
that guy Cruz may be best known for
playing Tuco on Breaking Bad and
detective Julio Sanchez on the closer
and major crimes but he's actually been
toiling away in Hollywood as a classic
that guy since the 80s he got his big
break in the now forgotten 1987 comedy
film made to order and has since landed
more than 80 film and television roles
from movies like clear and present
danger and training day to TV shows
including Cagney and Lacey and Murder
She Wrote we love it when a character
actor finally becomes a star good guys
and bad guys it's not that unusual for a
popular character to spin-off from a
show into another series
but Cruz holds the distinction of doing
it twice and at the same time while
playing detective Julio Sanchez on the
closer a role he originated way back in
2005 he moonlighted as Tuco on Breaking
Bad working seven days a week to film
both parts concurrently he apparently
liked the challenge though because after
detective Sanchez spun off into major
crimes
he then reprised his role as to go on
better call Saul at the same time given
that one character is a cop and the
other a criminal is it possible we could
ever see a crossover he loves to cook
one of Tuco's most intriguing character
traits is the fact that he really
enjoyed cooking not meth like Walter
White mind you but delicious handcrafted
burritos and other meals made with love
so where did to go get it from well from
Cruz of course who is a bit of a chef in
his own right
just don't bother trying to emulate his
grilled pork chop recipe because it
requires an ingredient not for sale his
mom's homemade chili
he told AMC I'll put it on the bed of
lettuce with a grilled jalapeno or a
small green chili take it to the point
just before it starts to cook completely
through and I'll top it with my mom's
chili and a couple slices of cheese man
is the best thing ever he's an introvert
Tuco might be a super intense
in-your-face villain but in real life
Cruz couldn't be more different
in fact he's basically an introvert
preferring quiet reading to drug fueled
rampages he told smashing interviews I'm
so quiet and I like to read I like to
tinker in the garage I love working on
motorcycles and cars I like to be alone
if I'm in a room with a lot of people
I'm probably the last person you'll
notice I'm practically invisible hard
pass when Cruz was initially approached
by the producers of Breaking Bad about
the role of Tuco Salamanca Cruz had a
simple answer for them no sure it's hard
to imagine someone else's to go now but
Cruz was concerned that filming both
Breaking Bad and The Closer at the same
time would be too much work for him but
finally they convinced him the
old-fashioned way by appealing to his
ego he told the a/v Club they couldn't
find anyone who could do it I was
shooting seven days a week with no rest
and working on two different things
was crazy Tuco's demise Tuco's demise
was shocking but even more surprising is
the fact that it was Cruz himself who
asked the producers of Breaking Bad to
eliminate the character why partly
because of his grueling filming schedule
but also because there was at least one
prominent fan of the show who really
disliked the character Cruz's wife Cruz
told Rotten Tomatoes my wife hated it
she hated Tuco she hated the energy Tuco
is this wild beast my wife is like get
away from me Tuco might be tough but
he's no match for an unhappy wife
[Music]